[Music]
on this tuesday night the future of the
astrazeneca vaccine in canada
ontario will no longer give astrazeneca
as a first dose
this decision was made out of an
abundance of caution
well alberta changes course too we'll
explain why
vaccination rates going up as case
numbers go down will that make any
difference to how we spend the summer
the outbreak in the oil sands the
conditions that led to canada's new
cobig 19 hot spot
an infected worker speaks out
and deadly strikes the worst outbreak of
violence in years as israel and gaza
are hit by rockets and home at last
the long ordeal of a quebec man detained
in the middle east
his secret journey back to canada
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with breaking news about the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine
ontario has announced it is pausing its
use as a first
dose because of the increased risk of
rare blood clots
public health officials say there is
more evidence people are developing
adverse reactions a month ago the risk
was believed to be
between one in one hundred and twenty
five thousand and one
in a million now officials say the risk
in ontario is about one in
sixty thousand there have been eight
cases of the rare blood clots known as
vit
reported in ontario
it makes sense to pause astrazeneca
because the risk of severe outcomes
with vit are shouldn't be underestimated
alberta has also announced it will no
longer offer first doses of astrazeneca
it says its concern is supply it wants
to keep its remaining doses for people's
second shot there's not a lot of
astrazeneca left in the country right
now there are about 8 400 doses in
alberta and about 50 thousand in ontario
and with uncertainty about future
shipments canada is relying increasingly
on pfizer and moderna
eric sorenson has tonight's top story
ontario has joined alberta in pausing
the use of astrazeneca vaccines for
first doses
cases of blood clots after use of
astrazeneca have increased
slightly from one in a hundred thousand
to one in sixty thousand
still extremely rare but it's one factor
in ontario's decision to limit
astrazeneca to second doses
this decision was made of an abundance
of caution due to an observed
increase in the rare blood clotting
condition
known as vaccine induced immune
thrombotic thrombocytopenia
alberta was the first to stop using
astrazeneca for first
doses it's not about higher risk for
astrazeneca says this specialist
the supply has dwindled of astrazeneca
and so
they are no longer able to provide
enough vaccines to give everybody the
second dose
if there's enough pfizer in the journal
vaccine
to to replace the astrazeneca then i
think that that is
a reasonable thing to do up to now more
than two million doses of astrazeneca
have been distributed across canada
but it represents less than 13 percent
of the total moderna accounts for 22
percent and pfizer over 64
of total vaccines distributed but
astrazeneca's share will shrink further
ottawa is expecting 1 to 2 million doses
of astrazeneca by the end of june
but more than 18 million doses are
coming from pfizer
the pfizer share is sure to increase use
of astrazeneca will decrease to below 10
percent
officials in ottawa still recommend
astrazeneca for first dose
and second so we will make sure that
those who got
the astrogenic vaccine the first dose
can be provided with a second dose
at the same time we're following the
evolving science
the evolving science however includes a
uk study expected late tomorrow that may
advise that a second dose doesn't have
to be the same vaccine as the first dose
which may tilt toward even greater use
of pfizer and moderna
what i do have concerns with
is you know the ongoing discussion
you know what dose number two looks like
for those of us who got astrazeneca
public health officials say astrazeneca
remains a safe vaccine
period but it looks like it will be used
less
going forward eric sorensen global news
toronto
prime minister justin trudeau said today
canada is on track for
a one dose summer meaning enough vaccine
is arriving to get every eligible
canadian a single dose
but that is not going to be enough
protection to lift all of the public
health restrictions over the summer
if we can do this then we can have a
more normal
better summer and a one dose summer
sets us up for a two dose fall when
we'll be able to talk about going back
to school back to work
and back to more normality
to ease restrictions the government says
at least 75 percent of canadian adults
need their first shot and 20
must be fully vaccinated as of today the
government says nearly 50 percent of
adults have had at least one dose and
about
3.4 percent have been fully vaccinated
here's the big picture of covet cases in
canada right now the curve is bending
downward
but the number of daily new cases is
still very high
more than 7 200 per day in the last week
and there are still hot spots across the
country where infections
are out of control one of those is
alberta's oil
sands thousands of workers have tested
positive for covid
12 plants have outbreaks yet they are
still operational staff continue to live
in close
quarters and workers are still flying in
and out from across the country
alberta's labor leaders are calling for
the plants to be shut down
the biggest outbreak is at canadian
natural resources horizon site
tonight heather urex west has an inside
look at how the virus was able to spread
so quickly when this oil sands
contractor who we've agreed not to
identify
took a job last month at cnrl horizon
he knew there was a chance he could get
sick a lot of guys
[Music]
and guys are getting sick that's the
story
the calgary man was one of thousands of
trades people brought in by the company
to perform
maintenance on the site but two weeks
into the job the 65 year old got kovid
19.
he spent several days sick and alone in
isolation on i was gonna stop site
and you know whatever like it was pretty
scary and i was really upset
in a series of employee memos obtained
by global news
the company delivered weekly updates on
the outbreak at cnrl horizon
the memos state the site had been
dealing with active outbreaks since
october
and there were 258 cases as of april 1st
but as the site entered into its
scheduled maintenance period in which
one of the memos noted there was a peak
workforce
of over 5 000 workers above our normal
daily average
cases of covet 19 began to surge
in an april 8 memo 44 new cases were
reported
on april 16th another 84 april 23
193 more april 30th and additional 268
and then another 219 positive
individuals by may 6.
according to alberta health there have
been at least 268 additional cases
reported
since then making this canada's largest
outbreak of covert 19
since the pandemic began at least two
workers
have died one of my brothers
that i worked with before many times has
died
the guy was a really nice guy this is
unfolding right now this is not
hypothetical
uh this is not something that we're
worried about it's happening right now
and so you know our members have are
scared the alberta federation of labor
is calling on the province to shut sites
with
major outbreaks down but the united
conservative government has deemed the
oil sands essential
instead the industry is focusing on
vaccinations
on-site clinics have already been held
at cnrl horizon
and two syncrude sites a clinic is also
currently underway at
suncor as well but that's all too late
for the thousands already
ill and for the families of those that
have died
heather urex west global news calgary
the federal government is committing 12
billion dollars in funding for five
major transit projects in ontario
the money will go to four subway
projects in the greater toronto area and
a rapid transit plan in hamilton
the funding is part of a deal with
ontario and involves ottawa picking up
40 percent of the costs
it is billed as the largest single
announcement of transit funding in
canadian history
public transit is at the heart of a
strong recovery
and a growing middle class it's also
part of our plan
to reach net zero by 2050.
investments like these are key to making
communities more livable
and affordable communities people can
love
to call home the projects aren't
expected to be completed until between
2029
and 2030. the federal government is
stepping up its legal battle over the
enbridge
line 5 pipeline natural resources canada
filed court documents today to formally
oppose michigan's effort to shut down
the line that supplies fuel to much of
ontario and quebec
the canadian government says it could
have a permanent impact on our economy
and
energy security michigan governor
gretchen whitmer says
she fears an environmental catastrophe
if the tap stays on
whitmer has given enbridge until
wednesday to shut down line five
the company says it has no plans to do
so
there is no peace in israel or gaza
tonight
[Music]
across tel aviv air raid sirens blared
and the skies lit up with a barrage of
rockets fired from gaza
three israelis have died it is
retaliation by hamas
for israeli airstrikes on gaza which
killed 28 people
and blew up a 13-story residential
building
used by the political leadership of
hamas
what began in jerusalem after israeli
forces stormed into the al-aqsa mosque
while people prayed has now spread
both israeli and palestinian leaders
caught up in their own domestic
political battles
are focused on holding on to power and
no one seems interested
in making peace redmond shannon reports
at a funeral procession in gaza a young
boy
sprints loose inconsolable
and desperate to stand beneath his
father's body
some of the gas and targets are
political or militant
other victims are innocents just like
this 11-year-old boy
as gazans bury the dead above them are
missile tracks
out of gaza
more strikes were aimed at israel
tuesday killing at least
two just north of gaza later
more death as rockets fell on tel aviv
its biggest city gazans fully aware
that israel will hit back again much
harder
i'm feeling this has to happen because
if it didn't happen
we will stay the same we will still be
suffering from electricity from water
from siege
or like we will stay
23 year old shireen sabah says her
family
barely slept monday night and fear they
could be hit next even though israel has
issued
some advance warnings
a building of more than 50 apartments is
just
it just fell down okay what about the
families of these apartments of these 50
families or more than 50 families
palestinian prime minister mohammad
shtaya accused israel of
war crimes his israeli counterpart
benjamin netanyahu said
the strength and frequency of the
israeli attacks
will only increase the u.s as israel's
biggest backer holds the power to help
de-escalate
but the biden administration sat
squarely on the fence
tuesday israel has the right to defend
itself
and to respond to rocket attacks the
palestinian people
also have the right to safety and
security unless something changes
soon there are fears a new and lengthy
conflict
could lie ahead redmond shannon global
news london
cultural changes in the military coming
up the latest plan for how the canadian
forces will tackle misconduct
within its ranks
there is another plan emerging for a
badly needed long-promised culture
change in the canadian military
the newly appointed senior officer in
charge of rooting out sexual misconduct
in the forces
testified at a parliamentary committee
today lieutenant general jenny karanya
says
she is still seeking clarity on the
exact scope of her authority
but as abigail beeman reports she has a
clear list of priorities
that training is not actually achieving
the aim of reducing uh
misconduct in in in any type of way
revamping sexual misconduct training and
the military's complaint system
it is not efficient it's very complex
two of lieutenant general
jenny carreno's goals the woman who
formerly led the nato mission in iraq
now
has more details about her new mission
on home soil
revamping military culture as we speak
now
i am taking people away from various
other organizations so that they can
start this very important work
kerinol hopes to issue new guidance on
inclusive behavior for leadership within
weeks
and have a mandate in place by the end
of this month this is a serious moment
for the canadian armed forces for the
military police
and for the military justice system
trust needs to be rebuilt
the head of military police also
testified they're working to support
victims better as well as revamp
training
critics say a big problem is a lack of
independence the brigadier general
insisted military police work
independently from the chain of command
but acknowledged an issue of perception
that can be
problematic for as a barrier
of reporting to the military police leah
west testified about her own military
sexual assault experience
and believes carynielle's appointment
marks a positive change
the senior leadership has accepted the
issue as a legitimate issue and is
putting forward real steps to make
change
in a way that i do not believe was the
case even three months ago
karen joel said she'll work closely with
louis arbor and implement any of our
board's recommendations along the way
rather than wait on a final report and
as for the
six-year-old deschamps report on the
same issue
amid much criticism over a lack of
implementation karineol vowed to move
forward on those recommendations as well
abigail beeman global news ottawa
ahead detained overseas for years for a
crime he didn't commit
the story of a canadian who is finally
home
my government's priority is to deliver a
national recovery from the pandemic
to achieve this my government today
queen elizabeth carried out her first
major royal engagement since her husband
prince philip died in april
she delivered the queen's speech opening
the latest session of parliament and
outlining the government's priorities
for the months ahead
the ceremony takes back hundreds of
years and usually involves lots of pomp
and pageantry
it was scaled back this year the queen
who is fully vaccinated didn't wear her
crown and only a small group who had a
negative covid test
were allowed to attend a quebec man who
spent time behind bars in the united
arab emirates is back home in canada
andre gautier had been detained off and
on in the middle east since december of
2015 over fraud allegations
his son says he was a whistleblower who
was just trying to alert
uae authorities to concerns related to a
gold trading company
instead of being rewarded gotra was
charged the canadian government stepped
in to help mike lacatura reports on the
breakthrough
that set him free i feel like
like relax it's andre gautier's moment
of relief
after spending years in and out of a
dubai jail
the quebec businessman is home in navy
after being caught up in an
international investigation fit for a
hollywood script
goldae built its success in 2015 gautier
was working at a mining company and
started asking questions about 30
million dollars that allegedly went
missing
senior management disappeared gotee was
named ceo
and then he was accused of embezzling
the money he was caught
as he fled to oman and gautier made this
ominous phone call
to his son it was two in the morning for
me and you just said alex i love you
tell your mother and my
sister i love them and i'll just forget
about me i think i'm
i'll be long gone now and i'm sorry
facing
45 years in jail gautier's family dug in
and pressured the canadian government to
intervene and they credit all three
foreign affairs ministers who worked on
the file
over the last two years gautier was
eventually granted a presidential pardon
on all criminal charges and then last
week
he got the call he had been waiting for
from the canadian embassy
get a ticket on ek 241 flight from
emirates to toronto tomorrow morning
nine o'clock
gautier spent three days in a quarantine
hotel and is now isolating at his home
with his wife the quebec man's ordeal
seems short compared to the plight of
michael
kovrig and michael spavor arbitrarily
detained in china
but gautier believes their families
should stay strong
be confident that the authorities are
doing all what they can at least to do
this i mean to take them out
a message of hope from a man who at one
point thought
he'd never make it home michael couter
global news ottawa
how to stay healthy next finding
motivation to get moving while stuck
in the pandemic
of all the challenges during the
pandemic how we look and whether we fit
into our pre-pandemic clothes is the
least of our worries
and it's especially vexing when
celebrities whine about their
circumstances
actor will smith posted this claiming he
is in the worst shape of his life
really what does that say about the
average 52 year old man
gwyneth paltrow says she went off the
rails drinking alcohol making pasta and
even eating bread maybe it's just me but
is it wrong to say
shut up already for most regular people
who can't spend their days working out
staying healthy has not been easy
and that's okay robin gill reports
[Music]
pop-up fitness classes are taking over
vancouver parks
the climate is conducive and it's
socially distanced
dana schmall has been getting back to
working out outside
the 38 year old graphic artist admits
she's been indulging
i'm a bag's a cookie person and how many
bags
at least half to one all those cookies
raised the kilograms on the scale
at least 10 pounds i think most
canadians can relate to the pandemic
pounds
these latest statistics are an
indication our calorie intake
is on an uptick 24 of canadians report
drinking more booze during the pandemic
one in five canadians reported using a
food delivery service
frozen pizza sales are up 20 percent
plus
we're not as active a survey by mcmaster
university found people are sitting more
and moving less canada's fitness
guidelines recommend 150 minutes of
activity
a week eighty percent of us are not
meeting those guidelines
the chronic stress of the uncertainty
surrounding the pandemic makes many feel
less motivated
they're depressed they're feeling
anxious afraid
stressed and all of this is making it
more difficult for them to be physically
active
but some is better than none because
it's also about mental health
ruby scott knows it's easy to reach for
the chips and give up exercise
instead she reaches for the dog leash
and a chance to get outside
if i let those things slide i'm between
that and
letting my routine go i would be a mess
that idea is what got dana schmall back
on track too
and she's not giving up her treats i'm
just gonna work out and eat cookies
a cookie here a cookie there as long as
she keeps moving
robin gill global news vancouver
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is nelson bc
there are beautiful spots all over
canada please email us yours
to viewers at globalnational.com thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]